[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja fast vier monate krieg in der ukraine
und der tobt immer blutiger im osten des
landes allein aktiv kam gestern bei
russischen angriffe 16 zivilisten ums
leben und auch in anderen regionen blick
schauen uns das mal an nämlich hier in
der region nur hans gibt es extreme
russische offensiven die hier weiter
gehen allein gestern wurden etwa fünf
dörfer eingenommen die ukrainische armee
hat sich hier zurückgezogen und wir
sehen uns einmal an ganz kurz wo das
ganze sich sicher abspielt nämlich hier
rund um die station etsc und residenz
das ist die schwesterstadt gleich auf
der anderen seite des flusses dort
versuchen die russen schaffen fakten zu
schaffen und wir sehen uns hier einmal
jetzt neues material der russischen
armee an hier sehen wir angriffe
russischer bodentruppen die also hier
mit panzerabwehrraketen auf der einen
seite und wir sehen uns dann gleich auch
mit schweren maschinengewehren die hier
stehen auf der anderen seite fortgeführt
werden auf dem boden dort rücken gruppen
vor aus dem ort postiv ska ist das ganze
und versuchen eben dort und auch
teilweise erfolgreich die ukrainische
armee zu überrennen und weiter zu
vertreiben gestern ist das relativ gut
gelungen aber nicht nur die wir hier
sehen einzelne soldaten kommen zum
einsatz sondern eben auch die schweren
mir mehrfach raketenwerfer bm 27
aufnahmen ebenfalls gestern von der
russischen armee
veröffentlicht sieht man hier wie sie
zum einsatz und fahren wir sind über das
set da vorne drauf das zeichen der
russischen invasion und ihr gemahl die
in die mitte dieses videos und sehen uns
an wie was dort passiert 22 cm
durchmesser haben dieser raketen sind
also wirklich sehr mächtige raketen mit
einer reichweite von bis zu 70
kilometern
sehr ungelenk sehr ungenau aber eben in
dieser schieren masse die russland davon
einsatz in der schieren masse man sehen
es hier wie die raketen gestartet werden
aus dem führerhaus dieses dieses lkw
sind sie halt wirklich tödlich und wir
sehen uns hier zwingend die ukraine
immer weiter sich zurückzuziehen was
haben die ukrainer dem entgegenzusetzen
seit heute endlich muss man sagen
endlich die deutsche panzerhaubitze 2000
wir wissen dass die gestern offiziell
angekommen ist es war hoch geheim
wahrscheinlich schon vor mehreren tagen
und seit heute morgen ist sie im einsatz
im osten der ukraine das haben wir aus
vier quellen erfahren dass hier erst mal
alte bilder von der bundeswehr es gibt
noch keine aktuellen bilder aber wir
wissen das seit heute morgen im don was
mit der panzerhaubitze 2000 gekämpft
wird und die ukraine sagen dass sie seit
4 uhr heute morgen im einsatz ist und
dass sie den ganzen tag seitdem schießt
und russische ziele bekämpft dass also
die nachricht die wir aus kiew bekommen
haben
doch das reicht der ukrainer noch lange
nicht man muss sagen es sind zwölf stück
maximal wenn alle aus holland und
deutschland eingetroffen sind apropos
holland was wir hier sehen finde ich
persönlich ziemlich beeindruckend diese
gepanzerten fahrzeuge vom typ solon pr
765 sind im osten der ukraine angekommen
und sie sind alle holländischer bauart
alle holländische fahrzeuge das heißt
unser kleines nachbarland liefert hier 1
2 3 4 usw
umgebaute m 113 aus den usa in eigener
produktion hergestellt die kommen immer
mehr das ist extrem wichtig für die
ukrainischen soldaten sie brauchen das
um sich fortzubewegen sich schnell fort
zu bewegen und sich gepanzert
fortzubewegen und eben dem feind auch ja
im monat von gegenoffensive etwas
entgegenzusetzen weil allein zu fuß
haben wir folgen gesehen ist das sehr
schwierig wenn der gegner über schwere
waffen verfügt insofern dass hierfür die
ukraine eine ein wichtiger eine wichtige
waffe zu guter letzt wollen wir uns
ansehen wie die ukraine sich auch
während nämlich heute morgen haben sie
damit angefangen wir werden gleich
aufnahmen sehen aus der stadt nur wo
schacht teams keine stadt etwa hier im
gebiet rostock und wir sehen gleich dass
die ukraine über die feindlichen linien
über die volksrepublik hinaus mit einer
kamikaze drohne dort eine raffinerie
angreifen und die aufnahmen sind wie
gesagt ganz frisch und sind relativ
beeindruckend war nämlich die
raffineriearbeiter die gleich den
angriff auf sie auf ihre raffinerie dort
filmen das zuerst überhaupt nicht
glauben können wir sehen hier oben die
ukrainische drohne die sich also hier
nähert und wir hören einfach mal rein
die raffinerie mitarbeiter sind erst mal
am lachen und sagen das ist ja
interessant was kommt da ist das eine
ukrainische drohnen ein ist es nicht
auch keine ukrainische drohne doch diese
gute laune die sie eben haben wird kurz
danach dann zur
üblen gewissheit dass sie eben hier
angegriffen werden
also eine eine noten lose drohne sagen
sie ist die ukraine nicht mehr ist sie
vielleicht aus der volksrepublik sonetts
nein glaube ich auch nicht er sagte ich
sehe sie nicht mehr sehen sie gerade
nicht mehr und dann die wörter braucht
nicht zu übersetzen
hier sehen wir also den einschlag in der
raffinerie an der raffinerie die genutzt
werden durch die russische armee um eben
gleich hinter der grenze zu tanken ihre
panzer zu betanken ihre ihre tanklaster
zu betanken und in der ukraine weiter
fortschritte in dem sinne also ein ziel
was aus ukrainischer sicht auf jeden
fall als militärisch gelten kann und
seitdem seit mehreren stunden ist diese
raffinerie jetzt anbrennen und die
russische feuerwehr ist dort im einsatz
gerade um zu löschen das heißt die
ukraine wollen sich nicht nur auf ihrem
gebiet verteidigen so wie es jeden tag
tun sondern tun jetzt gleich ist ja
sozusagen tunis den russen gleich
begreifen ihre kritische infrastruktur
angreifen hier ein ziel an was die
russische armee nutzt um eben ihre ihre
invasionsarmee dort mit benzin zu
versorgen dass also die aktuelle lage im
osten der ukraine und die kämpfe nehmen
dort wie wir sehen weiter an intensität
zu